[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم مازال طبعا موضوع
طوفان الاقصى هو الحدث الابرز على الساحه
الاقليميه والدوليه وبكل الناس بتحاول ان
هي تستقر ما قد يحدث في الايام المقبله
الايام المقبله سوف تشهد احداث ان جسا
وعليه فاحنا ايضا من جانبنا في هذه الحلقه
وفي لقائي مع استاذي الدكتور احمد يوسف
احمد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بنحاول
استقراء المستقبل القريب جدا ماذا قد يحدث
هل تقبل اسرائيل على تنفيذ تهديداتها
باجتياح غزه واذا اقدمت ما هي النتائج
المحتمله وماذا قد يترتب عليها محليا في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله والنتائج على
اسرائيل وعلى على المنطقه العربيه مساء
الخير معال الدكتور مساء الخير يا استاذ
سيد تتوقع ايه في الايام المقبله معال
الدكتور في ضوء المعطيات اللي متاحه
لحضرتك الان ا طبعا كويس ان حضرتك قلت في
ضوء المعطيات لان بالتاكيد هناك تفاصيل ا
تغيب عنا
كمتابعين لا علاقه مباشره لهم لا
بالبنيه الاساسيه لحماس ولا بما يجري في
دواء القياده الاسرائيليه الى اخره لنفترض
انه
خلاص اتخذ القرار انه القياده العسكريه
الاسرائيليه اطمانت الى انها اجرت من
التمهيد ما يجعلها تقدم على الاجتياح
البري ولم تلق بالا الى نصائح حلفائها انه
تمهلوا او تعقلوا او شيء من هذا القبيل
هنا اعود الى انه هناك سيناريوهان لا ثالث
لهما السيناريو الاول ان خبره حرب المدن
تنطبق تنطبق بطريقه نموذجيه اي ان القوات
الاسرائيليه التي تنوي اجتياح قطاع غزه
سوف تجد مقاومه ضاريه لا قبل لها
بها وانا اود فقط ان اشير الى انه ليس من
المستحيل ان ما حدث يوم 7 اكتوبر يحدث في
اليوم الاول للاجتياح البرد وهنا ستك في
الاسرائيلين بالضبط وهنا ستكون طامه كبرى
وهذا السيناريو مرجح براي عديد من الخبراء
العسكريين الغربيين قبل الشرقيين يعني
يمكن الشرقيين نقول دول متعاطفين معانا او
العرب طبعا هذه قضيتهم لكن هناك الخبراء
العسكريون الغربيون يشتركون في هذا فهذا
هو السيناريو الاول الذي اضرع ال الله
بالضبط الذي اضرع الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يحدس انه يتعثر الاجتياح وتلحق
المقاومه خسائر ضخمه بالاسرائيليين وتفشل
العمليه بالضبط لانه في هذه الحاله سيكون
هناك فشل ذريع لاسرائيل احد العسكريين وهو
يعني شخص يعني يعني محلل عسكري مصري معروف
العميد سمير راغب كان بيقول انه الطبيعي
بغض النظر عن اسرائيل او المقاومه انه اذا
كنت انت في موقف المدافع فانت عندك ميزه
انك يعني تحتاج ثلاثه يهاجموك واحد لكل
ثلاثه وفي حاله التمترس الشديد وفي حرب
المدن ممكن يحتاج المدافع ل 26 مهاجم يعني
لكل مقاتل حمساوي او فلسطيني لانه مش لازم
بس حماس اكيد الجميع سوف يقاتل يعني يحتاج
كل واحد 26 جندي اسرائيلي ف ف بدلل ان ده
امر بالغ الصعوبه على القوات المهاجمه
السيناريو الثاني مع دكتور تمام وانا
انتهز هذه الفرصه لتوجيه تحيه للعميد سمير
راغب لانه بيمتع بصوت العلم العسكري
والعقل في مواجهه كثير من الخزعبلات التي
توجد في
الفضائيات الاجنبيه بالذات حول هذه هذا
الموضوع السيناريو الثاني لا قدر الله انه
طبعا من المؤكد انه ستحدث عقبات وخسائر
كثيره لاسرائيل ولكن لا تكونوا الى
الحد الذي يوقفها عن اتمام العمليه ويعني
هذا لا قدر الله ان تهزم حماس وتتوقف
مقاومتها ويتم تدمير الجزء الاكبر من
بنيتها العسكريه تمام ساعود بعد ذلك
لتوسيع نطاق الحرب لكن اريد ان اركز على
هذا
السيناريو وفي هذه
الحاله قد يتصور البعض ان هذه هي النهايه
ولذلك اكرر ما قلته انه في
هذه الاحوال عاده فانه لا توجد نهايات
لحركات المقاومه ممكن الصمت يدوم شهورا
يدوم سنوات ما فيش اي مشكله التاريخ بيقول
لنا كده ولكن
سوف تشتعل المقاومه من جديد اذا السيناريو
الثاني سيكون هزيمه مؤقته يعقبها صحوه
وانا اقول او اوجه هذه الرساله لكل من يضع
يده على قلبه تحسبا من تطورات سيئه حتى
لولا قدر الله حدثت هذه التطورات ولن تحدث
باذن الله فان هذا هذه هي سنه التاريخ انا
بس انا اسف انا قلان معال الدكتور انا
متعود من حضرتك على التحليل العلمي بس انا
المس طبعا وانا الومك لا الومك في ذلك هو
الوش فكين الامنيات فحضرتك بتتكلم على
تحليل ولا امنيات لا انا بتكلم انا لما
بقول لما باظهر تحيز انا بظهره بالدعاء
لكن انا قلت ان هناك سيناريوهين اه في
سيناريو النصر ان شاء الله وفي سيناريو
الهزيمه بعد خسائر فادحه لا قدر الله لكني
علميا وليس بقى كنوع من الانحياز لكني
علميا اؤكد من دروس التاريخ لا توجد حاله
استثناء واحده من دروس
التاريخ اي نكسه اه طبعا بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لانه قبلها الوضع مختلف
في كل حركات التحرر الوطني بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه لا توجد حركه انتكست
بمعنى عجزها عن تحقيق اهداف بمى ان
تث تماما تماما طيب في حاله اذا اذا حدث
السيناريو الاول هيكون له عواقب واذا حدث
السيناريو الثاني هيكون ليه تداعيات
السيناريو الاولاني انه اسرائيل تلحق بها
خسائر كبيره وتضطر للانسحاب زي ما انسحبت
الولايات المتحده من افغانستان ففي الحاله
دي تتوقع ان التوابع تكون هو طبعا انا
اعتقد ان هناك توابع قد حدثت بالفعل داخل
اسرائيل ل طوفان الاقصى من هذه التوابع
اضطرار نتنياهو الى تكوين حكومه وحده
وطنيه انا اذهب الى ابعد من ذلك انه اذا
حدث بعد اسبوعين او شهر او اكثر او اقل ا
انه انتهى القتال على اي صوره من الصور
لابد انه ستكون لطوفان الاقصى ان ارتدادات
انعكاسيه خطيره على البنيه الاسرائيليه
السياسيه بمعنى نحن نعلم الان ان حكومه
نتنياهو تضم اقصى العناصر تطرفا في
اسرائيل انا اتصور ان هذا لن يدوم لاني
اعتقد انه الراي العام الاسرائيلي سيصل
الى النتيجه ان هؤلاء الناس بالذات
الوزيرين اياهم دول شهدت اسرايل بالضبط
شهدت اسمت وزير
الملا شهدت اسرائيل في ظلهما اكبر اهانه
لاني سبق ان ذكرت انه الاسرائيليين يبدوا
وكانهم مستعدين لابتلاع اهانه اكتوبر لان
مصر دوله كبرى في المنطقه انما ان يصل
الامر ان حماس تلحق بهم هذه الاهانه فلن
يغفر الاسرائيل الاسرائيليون لحكومه
نتنياهو ما فعلته بهم انا عاوز استاذن
حضرتك في اضافه صغيره انه المساله ليها
بعد اخر مش بس بين غفير و وزير الماليه
سموتريتش
ا مش بس ان هم يعني ما كان لهما ان يكون
جزء من اي حكومه حتى لو حكومه اسرائيليه
براي نتنياهو اللي كان بيقول هذان لا
يصلحان يعني ولكن اضطر للتحالف معه ولكن
الاصوات اللي كانت بتقول انه ما كان يجب
السماح ل نتنياهو نفسه ان يظل في السلطه
وهو ملاحق قضائيا وفي عدد من الاصوات
وطبعا اللي هم بيحسبوا على اليسار بيقولوا
هذا ما سوف يحدث لاسرائيل بعد ان سمحت
لشخص مطلوب من القضاء بان يتولى السلطه
هيحاول الهروب من مشاكله الداخليه بتوريط
اسرائيل في مغامرات خارجيه لا تنتهي انا
اسف ان انا قطعت حضرتك لا انا اقطع والقطع
في التحليل السياسي صعب لكن اقطع بان
طوفان الاقصى وضع نهايه للمستقبل السياسي
لنتنياهو اما في اعقاب انتهاء هذه العمليه
مباشره واما في اول انتخابات اسرائيليه
قادمه لانه اداء الحكومه على هذا النحو
كان قمه في الغطرسه والاستخفاف
بالفلسطينيين واهانتهم واهانه مقدساتهم
فماذا كانت النتيجه ضربه غير مسبوقه
لاسرائيل من المقاومه الفلسطين هذا عن
مستقبل الحكومه الاسرائيليه هل حضرتك
تتوقع توا ارتدادات اخرى على الاسرائيليين
اذا في حاله فشل العمليه طبعا هناك مساله
يجب ان تدرس علميا ان طبعا معروف ان
اسرائيل
ليست وطنا قديما لكل من فيها هو في طبعا
اجيال ولدت في
اسرائيل ولكن هناك اجيال غير متجذر في
اسرائيل وانا قرات وان كنت لا اعلم المصدر
او يعني شاهدت شريطا بان جمعيه تكونت في
اسرائيل تسمى اظن هيا نعود معا او حاجه زي
كده واقصد بهذا اثاره ان قضيه الهجره
العكسيه مثاره في اسرائيل منذ فتره ويقال
ان اسرائيل تخفي الارقام الحقيقيه لهذه
الهجره اتصور ان طوفان الاقصى يمكن ان
يكون عاملا محفزا للهجره العكسيه من
اسرائيل وهذا عامل في منتهى الاهميه
بالنسبه لمستقبل الصراع الاتجاه للخروج من
اسرائيل كان بدا على استحياء في اعقاب
الازمه السياسيه الداخليه ده صحيح اللي هي
تتعلق بالتعديلات القضائيه واعتراض بعض
النخب الاسرائيليه عليها تاكيدا لكلام
حضرتك هناك مقالات عديده ظهرت في صحف
اسرائيليه يعني لا اريد ان احدد نسبتها
ا لاني لا اعرفها لكن عدد من المقالات
التي
قراتها تتحدث عن معنى واحد ان تجربه
اسرائيل انتهى و انتهت وهيا بنا نرحل طبعا
لا استطيع ان اقيم مدى وزن هذه الاراء لكن
من المؤكد الذي استطيع ان اؤكد ان لطوفان
الاقصى كذه
لعمليات مقاومه لابد ان يكون له تاثير قوي
على مساله الهجره العكسيه طب هذا عن
اسرائيل هل حضرتك اذا احنا لسه بنتكلم على
السيناريو الاولاني اللي هو فشل الاجتياح
هل ده يكون له انعكاس بقى
على على الفلسطينيين على السلطه على لانه
ممكن يبقى ليه حاجات ايجابيه او حاجات
سلبيه هل ممكن في نقاط مختصره ما قد يترتب
سلبا وايجابا على فشل اسرائيل في الاجتياح
البري حسب السيناريو احنا قلنا ان فشل
احنا بنتكلم الاول على الفشل لسه على
النجاح طبعا الفشل هيبقى معناه فشل
اسرائيل بتكلم فل اسرائيل هيبقى معناه
صعود قوه حماس بدرجه واضحه وملموس على
حساب مين على حساب السلطه الفلسطينيه لانه
في انتخابات 2006 كما نذكر حماس فازت
بالاغلبيه في انتخابات ديمقراطيه ثم حدث
ما حدث من صدام مسلح مازال ما زالت
تداعياته موجوده حتى سنه طبعا لو حدث
سيناريو فشل الاجتياح البري هذا معناه ان
حماس باقيه ومعناه ان هي قدمت اداء لابد
وان يشفع لها لدى الراي العام الفلسطيني
بحيث انه اما ان تتمتع بشرعيه اقوى في
اوساط الفلسطينيين بدون انتخابات واما انه
لو اجريت انتخابات فيكون يكاد ان يكون من
المؤكد ان تفوز بالانتخابات لسبب بسيط
انها فازت بها في ظروف طبيعيه سنه 2006
قبل ما تعمل اي حاجه فما بلنا بعد طوفان
الاقصى اذا على الارجح في حال فشل العمليه
العسكريه البريه الاسرائيليه انه بقدر ما
لذلك من مكاسب
و يعني سوف يبتهج به الكثيرون ان لم يبتهج
به الجميع يعني لكن الجانب السلبي انه سوف
يعزز الانقسام الفلسطيني بين قوه منتصره
سوف ترتفع اسهمها على حساب السلطه
الفلسطينيه ونظل بقى ندعو الله لتحقيق
الوحده يعني ا يعني هذا كلام سليم وهنا
يعني اود ان اضيف يعني انه في اداره هذه
العمليه لا مانع من ان تكون هناك نصائح
مفيده لان احنا لماذا نمارس التنبؤ
واستشراف المستقبل حتى يعني يساعدنا في
توجيه مسار الاحداث فحضرتك بتقول كلام
سليم انه ممكن لو برز نجم حماس قد يؤدي
هذا الى تاجيج او استمرار ال الفرقه
والانشقاق انا اتمنى في هذه الحاله ودي
ليس تحليل علمي وانما توصيات اتمنى في هذه
الحاله ان يكون هناك نهج من حماس لتحقيق
الوحده الوطنيه في ظل ظروف لا شك انها
ستكون مواتيه له يعني بمعنى انها تدخل
مثلا في منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه بضمانات
معينه وتجرى انتخابات
وما الى هذا وبالتالي في
مواجهه سيناريو بقى الانقسام الفلسطيني زي
الانقسام الاسرائيلي ليتنا نكونوا متحسب
له لانه يجب ان ندرك باسى ان الانقسام
الفلسطيني عطل مسار القضيه الفلسطينيه انا
طبعا يعني اتمنى ان ده يتم ولكن لكن وفقا
لفهمي المتواضع وارجو ان تصحح ني ان هذا
سوف يظل في الابد القريب واتمنى الا يحدث
يعني هيكون امنيات لان المساله هيكون في
قوى اخرى هتضغط على
السلطه والتوجهات اللي هي بتمثلها حتى
ابدا لا تدفي حماس لان في قوى عربيه قبل
ان تكون اقليميه ليس من مصلحتها ان حماس
يعني تسيطر على كل الاراض المحتله قد اكون
مخطئ ولكن هذا ظني يعني لا ليست مساله خطا
هو هو بس التحفظ انه ما لم تقم السلطه لان
هي السلطه دلوقتي مشكلتها ايه مشكلتها ان
النهج الذي تبنته لمعالجه القضيه
الفلسطينيه لم يحقق اي شيء فشل اللي هو
نهج اسلو اكثر من 30 سنه اسلو بدون اي
انجاز اللهم الا تغو الاستيطان وما الى
هذا فهنا لكي تبقى للسلطه اوراق لابد من
ان يكون هناك انجاز محدد انا شخصيا اتمنى
واقترح انه بعد هذه العمليه لابد من اجراء
انتخابات وعدم التذرع بانه مش هنقدر ننتخب
في القدس الشرقيه او شيء من هذا القبيل فل
يعبر الشعب الفلسطيني عن ارادته وناخذ
بنتائج هذه الانتخابات النزيهه هروبا من
استمرار الانقسام الفلسطيني طب هذا عن
السيناريو الاول وهو فشل الاجتياح البري
الاسرائيلي طب احنا بنتكلم على
السيناريوهات احنا بنتكلم على سيناريوهات
سياسيه وليست عسكريه هذا ليس شان معالي
الدكتور ولا شاننا يعني العسكريين ممكن
يتكلموا عن
التفاصيل السيناريو الثاني
انه تنجح اسرائيل وتستطيع تدمير الجزء
الاكبر من البنيه العسكريه لحماس وتلحق
خسائر ضخمه بالقطاع وتزيد معاناه
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي هيكون في تداعيات
كبيره على القطاع وعلى دول الجوار
طبعا الحقيقه انه السيناريو الثاني ان
اسرائيل س يعني تتمكن من تحقيق اهدافها من
الاجتياح البري ولو بتكلفه عاليه انا رايي
انه سيكون بدايه لمشكله خطيره جديده لانه
ها قد دمرت اسرائيل يعني قطاع غزه بنسبه
لا يعلمها الا الله انا لا اعلمها الان
لكن ك
نرى ما يحدث في الشرائط التي تدعها
القنوات الفضائيه وبالتالي عندنا مهام
جسام تحتاج دعم دولي خطير
وتحتاج يعني سلطه فلسطينيه قادره اقصد
يعني سلطه سياسيه جديده في غزه او شيء من
هذا القبيل ولنتصور مثلا ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه ستتولى مسؤوليه قطاع غزه ف
ماذا ستكون النتيجه يعني اقصد انه سيناريو
نجاح اسرائيل سيكون بدايه
لمخاطر جديده طبعا انا استبعد تماما مساله
تهجير الفلسطينيين الى الى سيناء او غير
سيناء اولا لانهم لا يريدون من المؤكد
ثانيا لان مصر ترفض بحق ان يكون في هذه
نتيجه هذه العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
تصفيه للقضيه الفلسطينيه
والفلسطينيون وقياداتهم من كل التوجهات
حماس وسلطه والى اخره يرفضون هذا وبالتالي
في رايي ان سيناريو النجاح الاسرائيلي
سيكون بدايه لمشكله خطيره اللي هي مشكله
اقتصاديه ومشكله سياسيه احنا الان لمين
يعني للقطاع ولا لمين المشكله لكل الاطراف
يعني اسرائيل ان ان استمرت في الاحتفاظ
بما هو احد السيناريوهات التي استبعدها
تماما ان اسرائيل تعود لحكم قطاع غزه لانه
هذه عمليه صعبه وان عادت عندها مشكله يعني
هي هزيمتها تخلق لها مشكله وانتصارها يخلق
لها مشكله لانها ستكون مسؤوله عن قطاع
دمرت دمرت بنيته الصحيه
وبنيته السكانيه وهي ك سلطه احتلال بتمارس
الاحتلال عليها مسؤوليه ان هي توفر تعيد
بناء كل هذا وتوفر كل الخدمات الاساسيه
يعني دمرت اسرائيل قطاع غزه وانسحبت منه
طبعا هي لا يمكن اذا حققت هذا الانجاز
انها تتركه هكذا وبالتالي لابد هيبقى
قنبله تنفجر فوق بالضبط وبالتالي هتبقى
معنيه بترتيب الاوضاع في غزه وهذه مشكله
سياسيه لا نحن في مواجهه موقف يعني او
خطوه او مرحله من مراحل عمليه تاريخيه ما
لم تقتنع اسرائيل بان الحل الحقيقي هو حل
الدولتين سيستمر توالد المشاكل بلا توقف
استاذنك في ايجاز لو امكن ان انا الخص
الحرك قلته وبعدين نعرج الى السيناريو
الاخير اللي ممكن يترتب على او التداعيات
لمساله انتصار اسرائيل يعني او نجاحها في
تحقيق هدفها حك بتقول ان احنا قدام
سيناريوهين السيناريو الاول ان يتعثر
الاجتياح وبالتالي تنسحب اسرائيل دون ان
تحقق اهدافها من تدمير الجزء الاكبر من
البنيه العسكريه لحماس والجماعات المقاومه
وبالتالي ده يكون لتداعيات على الداخل
الاسرائيلي وتداعيات في انتصار حماس
وانتصار الجهاد وكل الجماعات الت تشارك في
العمليه العسكريه ما يجعلها يعلو شانها
وبالتالي اما ده يعزز من الانقسام
الفلسطيني او ربما يدفع دفعا الى السلطه
الى ان هي تسلم بالامر الواقع وتجري
انتخابات الى اخره ودي مساله محتاجين
نتابعها اثنين ان تن جح ان تنجح اسرائيل
وتقدر ان هي تلحق ضرر بالغ بالمقاومه
وتستطيع السيطره على القطاع وفي هذه
الحاله سوف تواجه مشاكل اكبر من المشاكل
التي ستواجهها لو خسرت هذه الحرب لانها
تجد نفسها بدون السلطه المحليه اللي
بتسيطر على القطاع اللي كان بيمثل كابوس
لاسرائيل لسنوات طويله وعليها ان تدير
شؤونه هتعمل ايه في القطاع هل تديره هل
تعود
لاحتلاله يعني
كيف يمكن ان هل مثلا سوف تدعو السلطه هل
السلطه سوف تقبل ولو قبلت السلطه في
اختفاء حماس ده يمثل مشكله اخرى لاسرائيل
لانه هيكون من الصعب جدا على اسرائيل ان
تتنصل من حل الدولتين اذا اختفت يعني فرض
كل حركات المقاومه وعادت السلطه المهادنه
مش كده مع الدكتور وهذا لن يحدث وهذا ل يح
لن يحدث طيب فاضل بقى
عندنا البجعه السوداء اللي بيقولوا عليها
السيناريو اللي ماحدش
يعرف اذا كان ممكن يحدث و لا وهو ان
الصراع لا يظل مقتصرا على غزه ولا ده مش
وارد ا يعني بغض نظر وارد ام غير وارد
لابد ان نناقشه يعني هو توسيع نطاق الصراع
ممكن يحدث على مستويين المستوى الاول ان
يصبح
شاملا لكل فلسطين وهذا يحدث فعلا في الضفه
ولكن بمعدل طبعا او يعني بوت
لا يمكن مقارنتها بما يحدث في غزه لكن
مثلا في الايام الاولى لطوفان الاقصى اظن
سقط اكثر من 60 شهيد فلسطيني ده دليل ان
هناك مواجهات متاجج في الضفه الغربيه
لدينا
ايضا جبهه اسرائيل داخل الخط الاخضر بما
فيها من فلسطينيه
1948 وهذه كانت قد تاجج في احدى الجولات
القريبه لا اذكر 2018 ولا متى ا يمكن
المره دي تكون اكثر حساسيه لانه طبعا ما
حدث لاسرائيل في طوفان الاقصى قد يجعل
السلطات اكثر عنفا في مواجهه اي نوع من
التمرد او شيء من هذا القبيل لكن يجب ان
نثير الاحتمال فهذا هو التوسيع الاول وهو
وبالذات في الضفه الغربيه يجري بالفعل لكن
لن تكون له القدره على قاب الاجتياح
ا البري التوسيع الثاني انه كان قد تردد
ان حزب
الله
هدد بانه
اذا تم الاجتياح البري فسوف يتدخل في
القتال طبعا الان تحدث اشتباكات في الايام
الاخيره بين حزب الله وبين اسرائيل ولكن
اي متابع يلاحظ انها اشتباكات منضبطه اه
طبعا يعني حزب الله يضرب ضربه محدوده
مدرعه ش فترد عليه بقصف
مدفعي الكل من مصلحته عدم توسع ا
القتال لكن انا لا استطيع ان اجزم بهذا
طبعا حزب الله لديه القدره لكن يعلم جيدا
انه اذا دخل في الحرب فسوف يعني تكون او
تتعرض لبنان لموجه من التدمير كالتي تتعرض
لها غزه الان وبالتالي اتصور ان حسابات
هذا الدخول شديده التعقيد لكن لابد و ان
نتحسب له لا احد الولايات المتحده بتتحسب
ليه وبريطانيا بتتحسب ليه ب حاملات
الطائرات حاملات حامله الطائرات واحده
وصلت والثانيه ظن في الطريق هذه ليس لها
من هدف سوى ان رساله الى حزب الله واي جهه
اخرى انه اذا
حدث توسيع لنطاق الحرب لان ده معناه هيبقى
بقى حرب اقليميه وحرب اقليميه خطيره ا جدا
انا حتى الان ما زلت اميل ان الى انه هذا
السيناريو لن يحدث لكنه
وارد استاذنك معالي الدكتور مع السيناريو
الثالث اللي هو حضتك بتقول انه مستبعد
اللي هو الحرب الاقليميه ولكنه وارد نتوقف
عند القدر ده ونستانس في حلقات اخرى
وخصوصا مع اتضاح الصوره تما ولكن عاوز
استاذن حضرتك
في شيء مهم جدا يعني وهي رساله جاءتني من
اكثر من صديق من عرب 48 بمناسبه حضرتك
بتتكلم على احتمال انا بيتواصل معايا عدد
كبير منهم في السنوات الماضيه لكن جاءتني
رساله
مخيفه وهو يعني طبعا طلب مني الا اذكر
اسمه وحتى وهو بيكتب الرساله حريص الا
يكمل الكلمات حتى لا يتم يعني اكتشافه
وبيقول خلاصه الرساله نحن نلاحق بصوره لم
يسبق لها مثيل من سلطات الاحتلال لاي شخص
يبض تعاطف او يعبر عن رايه فيما يتعلق
بدعم المقاومه وحتى هو بيستنجد من فضلك
انقل رسالتنا لاكبر عدد من الناس وانا
بعمل كده دلوقتي وان شاء الله نعملها لكن
ده يفسر ليه رد الفعل داخل على الاقل عرب
48 واكيد الضفه محدود بسبب الضغط الشديد
والملاحقه الشديده الاسرائيليه وداخل
فلسطينيه 48 اكثر لانهم تحت السيطره
الكامله للسلطات الاسرائيليه والموقف شديد
الحساسيه ده بيمس كيان اسرائيل وهيبتها
وقلوبنا معهم لكن لو تطورت الامور بطريقه
افلتت بشكل معين ممكن تحدث امور كثيره
واسرائيل في هذا مثلها مثل الدول
الاوروبيه فرنسا فرضت عقوبات سجن على
المشاركه في مظاهرات وما الى هذا جزيل
الشكر مع الدكتور الله يخليك شكرا جزيلا
لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى باذن الله